so high and the web accessibility
specialist here at Stanford I work out
of the university of communications I
work with Scott stocker from folks who
may know who he is he's been at Stanford
for a number of years lots of folks know
who he is
which helps me in my work and what my
work consists of it is a couple of
different things one thing is that I
assess Stanford websites particularly
focusing on high traffic sites and high
visibility sites access them and it's
the web content accessibility guidelines
Stanford focuses on its it's called
three high for sure you may hear people
pronounce it differently
but we came o sleep people know what to
eat
we came to point O and we focus on the
double any criteria I'm not gonna launch
into any discussion of those criteria
what they mean but the short version to
think about when you think about what
Craig is poor he you are perceivable
I actually think about them that way
very often because I kind of go back and
forth so that's alright boys this is
okay okay good so I work on assessing
websites and I also am building and it
is a journey to build a website for the
Stanford online accessibility program
and we call that here soap so
it's soap that stanford.edu and you're
welcome to take a look around and the
content will be growing as fast as I can
write it and get it posted so ah that's
pretty much the work that I'm doing
people that are the for those that are
students here at Stanford there's a
different office that would be available
to help you with accessibility needs in
terms of working with assistive
technology in terms of working with to
get your to get your documents for
example in accessible formats to you if
you needed a different format that kind
of thing
that's the office of accessible
education so there's there's sort of the
the website aspect of it and then
there's more the assistive technology
aspect of things so I just want to give
you a bit bit of a rundown bit of an
orientation of what we're doing here at
Stanford I have just my job has just
expanded become a Stanford staff member
as opposed to a contractor so I'm just
getting myself revved up here just that
just happened in the last two weeks so
I've got got my work cut out for me
we've got plenty to do I have no concern
frankly about job security there are
lots of websites and and things to be
looking at at the same time we also have
some good strategies here at Stanford in
place to help assure accessibility one
of those has to do any any of you all
heard of the Stanford Web Services the
group that has built a Drupal framework
basically that Stanford can use and that
framework has a lot of accessibility
features and functionality built in for
free and so if people use Stanford sites
they can you can get it up and running
with a website really quickly and and
get a lot of accessibility for free so
I'm gonna wrap up but I want to leave
you with two
books and then I want to take a little
bit of a quick poll in terms of to find
out who you all are so so that so that
folks who come after me will know who
they're talking to
so books I would recommend a recently
released book that I know Stanford has
it is a Rosenfeld Media book have y'all
heard of Rosenfeld media you should
because they've got all the great
accessible usability books and they also
have a great book where we're having
sort of crossover an interaction between
accessibility and usability which I
believe deeply in and that book is
called a web for everyone so it's
available electronically from state from
the Stanford library authors you'll
recognize when you see them names are a
little bit hard to spell Quisenberry
anybody heard of whitney quiz squeeze
and barry whitney Quisenberry and Sarah
Horton so that's one book and then the
other one was just crossing my mind when
Michael is introducing me so this is a
quiz for anybody who can remember
there's this really good user
interaction book not so focused on the
web but focused more on products and and
that kind of thing it's by Graham pull
in anybody know this book can't remember
the title that's right that's right so
that's a really good one if you haven't
taken a look I would say that it's sort
of one of the founding books in the
field so make notes of this and they're
there get you off to a good start a web
for everyone focuses a lot on personas
of people with disabilities and how they
use the web so that's what I got for you
today and to wrap up like to take we're
gonna do hand raising for sighted folks
and audio cueing for blind folks don't
shout out because it's I mean you know
speak up but it's not a competition in
terms of who wins
so don't skew the results so
so how first general question about how
many people in the room that it is a
predator seventy okay students raise
hands and give a little audio cue okay
Stanford okay excellent pretty much
cover everybody a public we got some
public people would like to come okay
thank you guys for your time and I know
I went over but we're done I'm done and
okay making sure that the web is usable
by all people I wanted to try to route
this topic of accessibility within the
context of cs540 seven so according to
cs540 sevens website this is a seminar
about people computers and design and
this is actually a really nice capture
of what accessibility is about because
accessibility intimately touches each of
these three things so we when we use the
term accessibility in the context of
technology we are typically talking
about people with disabilities
interacting with computers and in order
for people with disabilities to interact
with computers successfully in some
cases they need to use assistive
technology now one example of that that
we're going to focus on today is screen
readers and that's a piece of assistive
technology that blind people use to
interact with the web the
I swear design comes in is that in order
for your experience your web experience
that you're building the product that
you're building to be usable by somebody
say who is using a screen reader you
need to make conscious decisions about
how you design and engineer that web
experience you don't always just get
accessibility for free so I've been
talking pretty abstractly for the past
minute or so and it's not unreasonable
that you might feel a little bit like
Austin here right what does this all
mean right what does it actually entail
in terms of trying to make one's web
experience accessible to people with
disabilities
so we're hopefully going to explain some
of that today over the course of the
next 30 minutes prove to you that you do
need to make some conscious decisions
but also empower you guys to know what
to do whether or not you are engineering
a website designing a website doing
research from an HDI perspective on a
website it's important for each of these
people who touch a product to understand
a little bit more about what
accessibility is and what you need to do
to make something accessible in order
for the web in general to become more
accessible so to make us a little bit
less abstract and really make this a lot
clearer to you guys I'm going to pass
this over to Victor and the victor is
going to walk you through what the
experience is like for somebody who is
using a screen reader to interact with
the computer and interact with the web
need to come here right yeah so let's
just tear right here yeah okay let's use
the mic working hey little yeah hey
YouTube can you hear me
hello can you hear me oh yeah
alright I didn't have my coffee sorry so
hey guys thanks for coming this is
always great to talk to students I've
been one myself as you can imagine one
day and especially to your HCI people
this is like even more amazing this is
one of the areas that I personally work
in at PayPal but this is also the area
where I spend most of my life is just
making the darn computers interact with
me right this is just as big of an HCI
problems any uh any other one and most
of you interact with the world by
looking at things around you everything
is you've been bombarded with a lot of
visual information so naturally your
visual sense is overloaded and but
that's unfortunately pretty much the
most used sense out of all that you have
in my instance I'm actually on the other
side of the spectrum which means I can't
see anything and that means that I'm not
bombarded with all the junk that you
guys are this is a great thing I don't
see all the freaking ads and things like
that
another great thing I don't you know I
don't know I don't see all the popups
and animations but unfortunately good or
bad they do interfere with my experience
and I'm gonna show you in this in a
minute why so how do I interact with the
computer I use a technology that Jeff
already mentioned called screen reader
screen viewer is a slightly modified Li
misleading name because all of us are
screen readers right you guys read
screen right right so when I started
back at the University I had a lot of
screen readers people who would read
screen for me because at that time there
was no computers that I could take
advantage of but the technology I'm
talking about is actually a software
that is built into every modern
operating system Mac OS Windows
iOS Android you name it they all have
this software we call it screen reader
and essentially the task of a screen
reader is to communicate this
information that appears on the screen
to somebody who cannot see so this is
done usually via speech synthesis and I
want to separate those two things for
you right away because most people think
that speech is a part of the screen
reader this is exactly not not exactly
correct speech synthesis is different
from screen reader and we'll find out in
a moment why so let me see I haven't
used Jeff's computer before so let's see
what's gonna happen here voiceover on
Safari Facebook window Facebook HTML
that's cool all right so back in 2005 I
think of 2006 Apple said that we can
make it possible for any blind user to
come up to any Apple Computer anywhere
in the world press a shortcut key and be
ready to go at that time what you had to
do and on Windows if you're like on
anything before Windows 8 you still have
to do that you have to actually ask
somebody to go and download for you the
piece of software help you install it
launch it for you and only then you will
be able to go ahead and use the computer
with Apple all you need to know is that
when you press command f5 this thing
launches no matter what you do I use
whether you're reading your email with
your on Facebook or you know using
PayPal or whatnot it's gonna launch and
it's gonna start talking to you so from
then on most likely what's gonna happen
to you just gonna get confused because
you're like I don't know what to do with
this thing right because one of the
things you will find out that screen
your well not only that it talks which
you probably need to be able to
understand but it also will interfere
with the way you use the computer I'm
not gonna go into all the details
because it's a little bit may be more
advanced for this particular
presentation today but suffice it to say
that in order to be efficient and using
the screen reader you need to know how
it works I mean it sort of makes sense
right I'm in order to be able to to
drive to San Diego you need to know how
the car works right so same way so learn
the rules of the road so the rules of
the road for the screen reader is that
as a blind user Mouse is useless to me
number one so anything I do on the web
or anything I do on a desktop needs to
be available accessible reachable via
keyboard most of you guys probably know
the keyboard right how many keys you
think you know on the keyboard
what is the bit what is the biggest what
is the biggest key on the keyboard well
that was too quick what key do you need
to press to continue oh that's an old
microsomes oaks re press any key to
continue
okay okay so my instance just to keep
things simple I need to use mostly tab
key and arrow keys to be able to do
anything well not anything most
everything on the desktop there are
other shortcuts if you'll see me using
there specific to a screen reader and by
the way this particular screen reader is
called voiceover as I mentioned is built
into every Mac so this is great if you
don't believe me go to your closest
Apple Store and if you want to impress
your your partner or the sales rep rep
in the store just press command a5 and
like hey did you know anyway so that
that's that's fun if you don't actually
that is the coolest thing ever
okay so link face market finder so I'm
gonna go to the best of the first thing
I'm gonna do I'll slow this thing down
as you can imagine just like with the
car there are people who drive slowly
there are people who drive like crazy
and there are people in the middle
that's the same way we read with the
screen reader right speech is a very
personal thing
some people talk fast some people listen
fast
and so in order for me to be able to
interact with the screen I kind of need
to find what's the most what's the most
appropriate thing for my particular
ability to listen
most people owe you 100 pitch 50%
intonation 50% voice Alex rate 50% most
people listen all right did you get it
okay cool so for you guys I'm going to
slow down just because I'm really nice
person 50 percent 35 percent all right
actually you know this is 10 1% you got
lots of time
right we can sit here listen okay any
well go back to something more normal 46
percent 36 41 percent okay tell me this
is too fast and we can switch so I've
got this great I've got this thing
talking to me so now you know I can
switch the speed and again just want to
repeat this because in the field of HCI
is super important to be personalizable
right and so the same thing with the
screen reader is a piece of the piece of
software and I want to be able for it to
work for me as opposed to me work for it
all right I mean who is the master here
after all so and so so I set it to the
speed I want the other thing with speech
synthesis you can do because again some
voices are better other voices are not
as good so with the screen reader I can
actually go ahead and say you know I
pitch 50 raised voice Alex I like Ruth
different voice red has anybody here
loves Radiohead Kathy Alex Bruce friend
they use this voice I think on there
okay computer album personal folder so
if you don't believe me go back check it
it's pretty cool it's a very old like
Mac OS beyond of Mac OS 9 or something
like that
what is Kathy Alex anyway so there are
high quality voices they're like sort of
low quality and something
you can purchase them the most recent
mac OS comes with like 25 what voices in
25 different languages and with
different genders and I mean it's
amazing you can really adjust experience
any way you want you know just the same
way
Rea 41 pitch 50% you can go and change
it 75 percent 40 percent 30 percent 5
percent ok this dude is really seriously
35 50 percent volume 100% and you know
there's all kinds of other stuff so
there's volume and blah blah blah so
let's let's do this
actually I'm gonna postpone this
exercise for for for a second so to
navigate on on it for example on the
dock or on desktop I would be using tab
key or arrow keys and I expect the
screen reader to give me a feedback dock
find her
open one one thing about voiceover that
you guys may have noticed already muting
let me just double check in this show
Braille panel hi bring up the voiceover
Quick Start in this voiceover on finder
desktop yeah hide caption panel hide
caption panel show caption panel okay I
know Jeff on your screen where it
appears on the left side I think is by
traditional where it is you will also
see like a visual line that's telling
you it's telling you in text what the
screen reader is same don't assume that
this is the behavior this is just apples
trying to be cool which is great also
for educational purposes because if
somebody's deaf and they cannot hear a
screenreader
they can sit down together with somebody
who is using a screen reader and being
able to you know either work on the
homework together or just just interact
or whatever it's pretty nice feature
also great feature for developers in
fact a quick story that I heard from the
authentic I heard it from people who
worked on voiceovers that the way visual
panel was born is that it was actually
originally used for debugging purposes
because engineers hated to listen to
these synthetic voices and so they
figure out hey what if we just take the
output of the skin ring just put it in
the screen and then the product manager
walked in and he said what the hell are
you doing oh don't worry it's gonna be
gone by the time we go into beta it
won't be there it's like wait wait I
said what is it oh and then he looked at
me he liked the feature so much he said
we're definitely gonna leave it in the
product and send it up a really really
cool thing develop developers love it
and for you guys when you start using a
screen reader maybe just something
that's gonna help it make it easier for
you to to interact initially so back to
the dock so I'm gonna be using left and
right arrow keys and dock oh sorry he's
got a vertical dock now I remember
trash 20 of 20 so I'm using the up and
down arrow keys to move between the
items in the dock finder open one of 20
System Preferences two of 20 Launchpad
three of 20 dashboard 4 of 20 so pretty
simple right it tells you what icon
you're on anybody who is not currently
on a dashboard item to open - word press
ctrl anybody else who's not familiar
with accessibility can you did you
notice anything else except of the name
of the icon when it was spoken I'll give
you one more hint Microsoft Outlook 5 of
20 item do you open this application it
said Microsoft Outlook and and it said
something else
5 of 20 right so why is this important
to know
presentation but you know my
presentation is always like that so in
case I didn't know so anyway so the idea
is to let the screen reader user know
about the size of the control we're
dealing with right so in this case we
have 20 icons and we're on icon number 5
so it does help you to get oriented a
little bit so if in case you know that
your mail icon is at the beginning of
the dock you know you're not gonna go to
item 19 and then you know wrap around
but you're gonna go backward because
item 1 is closer to 5 so somebody
clearly thought about that kind of stuff
and and you know it appears to be very
useful before we get off the dock - more
launch pad system prep finder trap
finder open one of 20 what's what about
this one finder did here you are
currently on application dock
finder open one of 20 it said find there
open that's pretty neat right you are
currently on application doc do you open
this application if I went to Safari
open 8 to 20 as opposed to Firefox 7 of
20 it's pretty cool right so it tells
you which of the windows is currently
open so are currently on application dot
item do you open this application press
yeah this is the this is what happens
when you're beginner mode it gives you
all these hints and stuff so this is
pretty cool right again great for
somebody who cannot see because for you
guys you take this for granted you look
at this screen you like I know which
windows are open right for me I can go I
can have to go I have to go through each
of these elements and trying to figure
out so what exactly is open okay let's
let's move on one step further so there
comes a time where arrow keys and tab
keys aren't gonna do because you know
you need to be doing more complex
operations and just moving between your
items so for example you need to be able
to switch between windows so we know
that there's at least two windows open
on the screen finding and safari so so
rely on me command tab is going to
allow us to move between windows so
that's a built-in Mac shortcut key we're
gonna use let's see what happens there
Safari keynote find her
Safari keynote find her okay cool
so there's actually one more window open
light which is keynote his presentation
so how do I know that the keynote is
open there's a window you notice there's
a title in the window every window has
this title area or it tells you what's
the name of the app is especially on the
web will see instances where people
forget to put the title and so when you
move between tabs in the browser or you
move between windows and if there's no
title there then obviously it's a blind
user you have no idea what you're
talking about you interacting with so
simple thing like title in your window
gives a metadata for a screen reader to
announce something useful now
interesting enough in keynotes case
safari keynote keynote stanford cs5 for
seven window slide now that's cool right
so I know what presentation he's due
he's he's showing us what presidential
jeff has opened so this is nice without
having to do anything because the title
is communicating to me the name of the
document finder Safari Safari Tracy
message view window padding level one
link they cool okay it's great
so okay cool so as you can see the
context is very important these are this
is the title of the window and so to
finish the desktop keynote part of this
present furniture fine similarly you
know if you go to the menu menu bar
Apple find her I'm just using arrow keys
right now file okay so I found the file
menu file menu 25 items you heard that
before alright so it informs me that
there's 25 items in them you are
currently on a menu to choose menu item
press control and a lot of the other
transactions you would be doing with the
keyboard through the keyboard would be
pretty much what you guys would be used
to enter key to activate stuff you know
arrow keys to move left and right up and
down so on and so forth
so what I want to do closer I'm known to
to go over time and I didn't ask anybody
to alert me when the time is all right
so what I'm gonna do is move to the web
a little bit to talk about the web and
then we're gonna move into the topic
that excites me personally because I
work a lot on mobile stuff and that is
really you know what gets me going
I wakes me up in the morning literally
anyway okay so on the web similarly just
like we have on a desktop we have to
interact with the web page mostly well
not mostly but by default you you will
be using tab key to navigate that will
move you between focusable elements on
the page you will hear the word focused
especially those of you how many
programmers by the way are in the room
are there any developers here so you
hear the word focus being mentioned in
the context of accessibility many many
many many many times
focus events you know for object under
focus and things like that
very important why it's important
traffic
screen curtains on okay so I'm here on
this web page and you guys don't see
anything right me too
so how do you know where on the screen
I'm currently him anybody know of course
I'm just tricking you it's impossible
right because now you're your contextual
information is gone your two-dimensional
vision is gone and so what you're stuck
with is what I call is one-dimensional
vision and that is basically a linear
way to interact with the computer
luckily this situation has changed a
little bit with the introduction of
touchscreens but on the desktop we're
still largely talking about one
dimension especially as far as the
keyboard is concerned so let's say I
took you to a page new tab now in all my
questions for Jeffrey Microsoft Word
document what Safari so Safari one new
tab untitled search google or enter an
address address and search edit text
where do you think I am you are
currently on a text field inside of a
toolbar but that's only because Google
is built into the browser but I'm
actually on the address bar right that's
that's a third guess so let's do
something open location period M
unhighlight okay which do you think I'm
on you wouldn't know so so this is the
typical experience of somebody who is
blind I'm gonna refresh this page so you
guys can actually hear the title of the
page and this way you will know reload
page CNN doc 87% loaded
visited link image CNN list for screen
curtain off display bright brighten
cnn.com breaking news us world weather
entertainment and video news window so
that's the title of the page okay so you
kind of know that I am on cnn.com right
what else do you know about this not
much because we're right now on the
age and Aiza blind person have no idea
about things on the left on the right I
have no idea where those stories appear
so the way I deal with this situation is
that you start gather and you start
mapping out the screen little by little
so you start tabbing link link
International CNN International link
Mexico CNN Mexico link Arabic CNN Arabic
link TV list five items link CNN CNM TV
program link siani CNN inch blank CNN
okay before you fall asleep so so we're
going through some kind of toolbar right
and so if you just imagine I'll let you
use the for the rest of this exercise
let you just use your imagination you
literally have to go through the page if
you're a beginner especially you have to
go through this page it's like looking
through a straw you know you slowly move
asteroid cross the screen you're like
okay now I start getting it so on the
left side or maybe first comes the menu
bar then second comes eventually we're
gonna get like two top stories and then
we're gonna get to probably some kind of
advertising and then we're gonna get to
some kind of footer right so so this is
basically how a screen reader user works
to to learn about web page now we have
this language and I'll hopefully I'm not
gonna steal thunder from ramier but I
have to mention a couple of these things
so we have the language of the web
called HTML and HTML lets us mark up our
page in such a way as to make it easier
for somebody like a screen reader user
to dissect the page and avoid all this
repetitive tabbing so you do this only
when you absolutely have to but if the
page is marked up correctly you can
actually you can reduce the time that
you have to spend a tab in through the
page because HTML gives us features like
HTML headings
we've got form fields we have lists and
so if we use all this HTML correctly and
provide necessary semantic information
the screen reader being software as it
is
take advantage of that stuff it says hey
I'm smart I can figure that out I take a
web page I scan the Dom I can see the
heading so I can see links
now if the heading of course is only CSS
heading but you know it's not actual H
tag the screen you is smart as as it is
it would know that it's actually heading
so to show you what I'm talking about
I'm gonna turn on turn on the screen
let's see where's the curtain on okay
voiceover immunity oops voiceover link
hey screen curtain off okay cool
here we go I just want to double check
so what I'm gonna do I use this feature
of a voiceover is to show you like a
quick overview of this page padding's 37
items and you guys should see that right
so there's a list of headings and as a
screen reader user I can go through this
list and actually decide which of the
headings I really care about for
breaking news one link MERS reaches us
one link first u.s. case of deadly virus
is reported in Indiana for the latest
okay
so you've noticed that also it next to
the two each heading there's a number
right one four three two and so on and
so forth at this page by the way is
poorly structured but that's that's it
set separate stories I'm gonna cut this
out from YouTube video anyway no so so
these are different levels of headings
right just like in Word document when
you if you guys create bibliographies or
things like that or when you know when
you have like chapters and subchapters
and sections it's pretty much the same
way right except in HTML we use heading
levels to indicate that and yes there
are shortcut keys to let the users once
they know the page once they learn its
structure but a shortcut keys to say hey
you know what I know that my top stories
begin with heading level one so I just
want to jump between those I don't care
about other headings okay so all of
these things are available so I just
pick one of these headings let's say for
breaking news one link MERS reaches us
press Enter heading level one link MERS
reaches us and the focus jumps to to
that particular place on the page you
are currently on a heading level one
inside of HTML
you can see just immediately how by
using headings I already cut down a
number of keystrokes that I have to
press just to get to the middle of the
page so you know essentially there you
can see there are other things like
padding's lengths 391 items Wow see how
many times you'd have to tab 391 and
that's at best so there are also other
shortcut keys to get you to because
obviously not everything on the web page
is focusable there are some elements on
the web page there are you know there
are pieces of text
you know like subtitle of the stories so
there are shortcut keys to let you go
through that so I have I can simply move
through the Dom in English language okay
so let us quickly so this is in in
principle how screen reader works I'm
gonna see check out Jeff's shouldn't I
use Safari or Chrome open look Oh see on
Selection see . am on highlighted
insertion - Patti link a smoker so
without going to Facebook many of you
guys are using Facebook
I hear they currently on a heading level
one inside of HTML content and to mess
click no link not fowl next button
previous button hadn't found wait you
got it
trackpad commander okay one Facebook
link Facebook close tab Twitter tab I
also you said it so accessibility
twitter twitter HTML content okay cool
alright now it can use Facebook so yeah
I heard that teenagers are not currently
on HTML content to answer the oh
something oh yeah yeah we can use
something else open location
oh I'm sorry well Jeff I didn't mean to
mm-hmm I ask you password secure sign-in
but open WP om / comm / hey al Sal hey
all right
padding level 2 visited link Twitter
list so so when we're moving to the
world of web apps obviously not
everything is going to be as simple as
just like moving from link to link or
you know moving between headings and so
Twitter and Facebook and Gmail and some
other leading providers have done some
amazing job in sort of exploring how can
we take the web feather and not just
sort of you know for example take the
web feather when we have to deal with
web apps so for example in Twitter's
case and Facebook is the same but since
you know Jeff we couldn't get it working
so they're kind of like in parallel they
provide a lot of shortcut keys to let
the users feel like they're using the
actual app and not just website so for
example in Twitter's case I can use
actually let's go yeah I'm first PayPal
accessibility I can use letters J and K
to move between tweet feeds and the same
thing on Facebook use J and K to move
between posts which is really really
cool and you notice that screen viewer
will actually announce all of this magic
of course is done with the help of focus
right so every time the J key moves the
retweeted by PayPal accessibility so the
focus has been moved to that object
right so in this in this case is going
to be a tweet and then these are
similarly K and you guys those of you
who use vim anybody here uses vim yeah
too few voices yes that's okay because I
don't use it myself
I have other editors I like so um but
anyway so it's it's a pretty unique
thing to do you know J and K and but
this is okay because this is like you
know on YouTube the same thing you can
use J and L to move backward and forward
in the video and then K to stop and play
video so this really helps so now we're
moving into the space of you know not
just being like a
regular just looking at the regular
website but also working with more
complex applications so if I wanted to
know what shortcut keys are available on
Twitter or on Facebook anybody wants to
guess the shortcut key sorry yes you
know there's always one key right I mean
you guys know but security there's got
to be a public and private key without
those keys you can't get to the rest so
there's always one key you gotta know
right good guess anybody else what is
that first your work okay let's do
keyboard shortcuts alert dialog close
button all right so this thing pop top
it's got short list of shortcut keys in
this planner and also you may have
noticed that screen readers said
something like alert dialog which is
really important
this is going a little bit more into
beyond I think a basic stuff but
essentially one of the big problems on
the web is that while on a desktop you
have a clear distinction between what's
a window and what's not programmatically
it's actually broadcast it as a separate
window on the web we have only divs
right so people use divs and like yeah
it's a separate div so die you know make
it look like your windows it's a window
right well it's not the same for if you
use a screen reader because for screen
reader div doesn't mean anything so
there are certain super semantics we can
lay over in in the code to to
communicate that hey this is actually a
pop-up dialog which is what exactly
happened in this case and then I can
just use you know a grant note to use
these shortcuts users of screen readers
may need to toggle off the virtual
navigate enter so there's some
instructions we do G clickable F
clickable go to user clickable F F and
so on so forth you'd go and you study
all the shortcut keys but yeah this is
all you need to know even on Facebook
just press question mark and the
shortcut keys are there PayPal X so
essentially just a rama is gonna
summarize some of the stuff that I was
talking about but I want to spend a bit
of time on
on on mobile remember I told you that
I'm gonna keep my word where's this
where's a piece of technology that I
need to use okay let's hope nobody's
gonna send me any messages okay can you
give me yeah oh it's from here all right
yeah so um so in 2009
will it I mentioned this company Apple
they thought to crack the problem of
making touchscreens accessible for blind
people because you know it's all great
when you use a keyboard because you can
feel each and every key or even if in
the case of Nokia you can use buttons or
you know sorry no you know rim whatever
the older phones right and so what we do
with the touchscreen so they had to
figure out how to make the touchscreens
talk ok well the software part of it
isn't wasn't all that difficult right so
they took voiceover that they have here
they took it kind of rip it apart and
you know restructured and they put it in
the iPhone ok that's great we got their
first step what is the biggest problem
you guys are smart people here right
those of you who don't know how how
touchscreens work what do you think is
the biggest problem in making
touchscreens accessible for somebody who
is blind it has to do with gesture so
I'll give you a hint so you have a
screen reader it will talk so we assume
that what's the what's the big thing it
has to do something with the way your
gesture with the touchscreen press ok
right so what do you press ok so let's
say I want to find out where I press
what happens when I put my finger on
this screen but you know where your
focuses stop at once
- they sure would actually is it
to be simply execute that just you know
when the ship is you know about to sing
there's always somebody who's gonna say
this year so so congratulations to get a
medal that's exactly what they had to
figure out so president enough it's very
easy now for us to talk about it but
supposedly up until 2009 with all the
you know proliferation of mobile phones
somebody actually even the first three
models of Apple's iPhones they came out
without pretty much any accessibility in
them so it was really amazing when
somebody said actually we can do that
and basically all they had to do is to
take over the gesture so when you launch
voice over on your iOS device it it will
take over the gesture in such a way that
you touch once to hear what you're
touching and in the second and tab touch
twice to execute it so now make it
louder
right come on once I'm 2 p.m. ok is this
Friday May 2nd come on ready May 2nd I
forgot I need to are these corporate
phones actually you'd be surprised not
you know why because I think the speech
takes quite a lot of battery to cuz it
constantly keeps on talking but it'll be
great actually pointers double tap to
open that's being written off characters
language headings containers it's sounds
volume speech right a fifty forty five
percent forty percent okay cool okay now
hopefully you guys can see so i single
touch some time minders remind that
actual notes double tap to open and then
it gives me him to double tap to open so
if I wanted to see I don't know let's
say reminder store actually let's do it
double tap to open App Store updates
heading
you DoubleTap right from here on you
have two ways of exploring the
touchscreen
now remember voice over controls my
gestures so there is a way to ask voice
over to bypass a gesture means don't
know let me in the next gesture pass it
through directly to the app but by
default most users wouldn't want to do
that because it's pretty dangerous
unless you know what you're doing so I
can just start exploring the screen
updates heading purchased up to
Instagram version speak music version -
upside karma and featured tab one of
five near me search selected update
search near me
top choc featured tab one of five okay
you notice right away what happens there
right is that I can suddenly start
getting a spatial imagination of the
layout of the screen right so I've got a
tab bar at the bottom which consists of
five tabs selected Updates tab that
notice how voiceover tells me which of
them is currently active right when it
says selected NPR news version three
featured tab one of five top charts tab
two of five your me tab 3:05 if I tap
one of those what's a search selected
Search tab now search becomes a selected
tab so remember how I talked about
one-dimensional navigation on the
desktop well finally with tablets and
touchscreens with the screen reader we
can actually start getting a little bit
more into so I can start if I go to a
website and I learned that something is
on the left side I don't have to go like
you know one by one I can just scroll my
finger top charts tab selected search
updates or a few select thank you up to
big news instead Graham beats sidecar
right Version three beat music sidecar
right beats me Instagram open Instagram
button right updated so that's one way
so you can drag your finger learn you
know layout of the screen you can also
one of the things they've done is that
they said well you know it's gonna be
hard for some blind people to
immediately readjust to touchscreen so
we're gonna give them a feeling as if
they were using a tab key
so you can move through the hierarchy
on the screen by Nelson starting any
anywhere on the screen is the lamp and
just swipe in open peek music open
updated Exide karma open NPR open
YouTube open demo open next door it does
take a little longer but you know if
you're in a hurry or if you're just
exploring or let's say you know you're
you're not comfortable in using tax
exploration that's another way so you
can swipe right and left your me tab I
can store and so the last thing I wanted
to show you is that so as you can
imagine all of the gestures like single
touch - you know - - here double touch
to activate there's also of course you
can swipe left and right extras folder
messages and so on page 1 or 13 I don't
snore settings and so last thing I want
to show you guys is where to find its
general button because there is no
reason there is no reason why you guys
starting HCI should know how to use this
cool gadgets right text size ability
accessibility I think I already mention
100 times but I'll just say 800 first is
that it's built into every every every
every eye device can you imagine every
Apple TV has something some kind of that
you know iPod touch and iPad and iPhone
this boy zoom this is this is where
voice over so if you want to learn how
to avoid oh here's a voice I'm speaking
right speaking right speaker double tap
tap once to select it it gives you a
very basic instructions how to use
voiceover if you if you're not
comfortable getting yourself into
trouble you can always tell Siri turn
voiceover on or turn voiceover off in
iOS 7.1 I think of snow iOS 7 and that
always gonna get you out of trouble so
since you know we talked about desktop
we talked about mobile phones
I want Romeo to come up and talk a
little about the web and the reason why
we spend so much time talking about the
web companies like Facebook and Twitter
and PayPal is because web is really our
desktop of the future I think every
battle that's going
happen including the one with FCC is
gonna happen about the web right make
the web accessible keep the you know
flow of information going and and the
web is so important so this is why it's
so important for all of us to keep web
healthy and for you guys as developers
the people who design interfaces to be
doctors of the web but key keynote
Stanford's voiceover odd story prior to
working at Facebook I worked at Stanford
University as a web accessibility
consultant in Scott stockist team so I
want to shout out a thanks to him for
connecting us to the right people to
make this happen and I want to thank
Michael Bernstein for letting us present
here although none of us have our PhDs
so I gotta talk super fast because
they're running out of time for the next
five minutes I'm going to give you all a
crash course on web accessibility
you'll all be web accessibility experts
at the end of five minutes and then
since today is all about acronyms we saw
pour and so I'm going to leave you with
an acronym which will help you recall
all the basic principles of web
accessibility I'm going to try to do a
live demo with voice over so let's see
how this goes comment to get Paul
understandable and robust quit out of
water
so much for making this pocket
yes we are fumbling through this yeah
it's this is trying to jump out of
keynote yeah no I'm a bit nervous about
turning on voiceover okay let's get
started
um I'm gonna walk you through the basic
principles of web accessibility and also
try to relate them to design so I'll
start with headings we all understand
why headings are important for visual
design they help visually organize the
content on the website so it's really
easy to glance at the headings and know
what a website is trying to convey
but headings as Victor demonstrated
they're crucial for accessibility
because a person using a screen reader
is going to try to get the gist of a
website just by jumping through the
headings so let's take a look at that
with voiceover I didn't know Victor was
going to the school demo with cnn.com
but voiceover on safari accessibility
one zero one window accessibility
heading level 1 headings and semantic
markup I'm just going to jump through
the headings heading level 2 like this
heading heading level 2 and this one
okay the next door headings are marked
up using divs
and not cement you're adding level 2
inside of HTML commuting they're marked
up with divs and not semantics h2 tabs
and you'll notice that voiceover skips
these two headings
last heading heading level 2 and this
one voiceover odd so that's why it's
really important to mark up with your
headings with semantic age stacks the
next time I have here is a set of form
fields the first set of form fields I've
associated the labels with the form
fields with semantic markup that's a
label with the four attribute pointing
to the text field and the next set of
form fields I don't have the labels
associated with the text field that's on
semantic markup so let's see what why so
it does with this voice over on Safari
accessibility one-zero-one window
interact with accessibility one-zero-one
HTML content heading level one semantic
mark I can't interact with heading level
one semantic mark had it the new name
edit text okay it announced the label
for the field which is you are currently
on a text field inside of voiceover off
I'm trying to tab to the next field so
Victor do I need to do anything to tap
to the next text field it's not tabbing
when I tap to it so the original demo
was a lot more obvious because when you
tap to the fields voiceover will
announce the name of the field but I'm
just going to try to move through each
element now voiceover on so address any
text so why so it announces the label
which is address telephone edit text
okay no I'm gonna jump to the on
semantic markup and hit text blank edit
text blank edit text blank so that's why
semantic markup is important voiceover
are jumping to the next principle it's
images and non-text content I have here
a few screenshots from popular web
applications like Gmail and Microsoft
Word and the reason I've called them out
here is it's not clear to me what this
icons indicate until I activate them and
look at the options in the menu the
third screenshot here is from the Amazon
mobile app the icons are really clear
and as text right below the icons which
makes it obvious what the icons stand
for now if we're guy cons are confusing
for a sighted person it creates a really
painful experience for someone using a
screen reader because now they would
have to tab to the icon
activate it and then go through the list
of options in the menu to know what the
icon is representing so let's look at a
demo I have two images here the first
image I've associated it with some
textual description and I do this by
using the alt attribute in the image tag
and the first images without the alt
attribute and the second image I
associated with an alt attribute and
let's see what voiceover does when I
navigate to these two images voiceover
on Safari I interact with a one two
seven one zero eight four or underlined
one zero one five two two zero three one
zero eight four six one seven two nine
underline eight zero nine two four five
six nine six underline no dot PNG image
Facebook logo image voiceover odd okay
so that's short and sweet and this is an
easy problem to fix most times but this
is actually pretty prevalent on the web
there are a bunch of images that don't
have alt text associated with them and
they are inaccessible to screen readers
haha okay you hit the nail on the head
so I'm gonna I'm gonna cover that to a
sign of my talk the third basic
principle is keyboard navigation what
you see here is actually a screen shot
of a design document from the Salesforce
blog I thought this was interesting
because it was a design document calling
out tab stops and keyboard navigation
but um keyboard navigation was also
crucial to accessibility because a
person using a screen reader as well as
those with motor disabilities who cannot
use a mouse use just their keyboard to
interact with elements on the page so
let's look at a demo of this basic
elements like links buttons and form
fields which are marked up with semantic
markup get keyboard focus by default
when you tap to them but things get
interesting when you build custom
widgets and they're built with on
semantic markup like this fake button I
have here voiceover on Safari interact
with accessibility once your link focus
Lawtons button text field contents
did form field text fake button
clickable okay
voiceover odd this demo did not work
because I was supposed to tap to the
fake button and why so it would not have
tapped to it but something is broken
with the tab navigation right now and so
it did announce the name of the button
but if you actually build buttons with
just divs or spans and you try to tap to
them the screen reader is not going to
tab to those elements and we'll see in a
few minutes how to make this fake button
accessible but before that my last
principle this is a little bit of love
for designs to be compelling and for
them to create delay delightful
experiences to users we have to meet and
exceed users expectations and the same
is true for accessibility in addition to
focusing on headings keyboard navigation
and non-text content we also have to
augment our HTML document with some
additional attributes that convey this
extra information to screen readers and
that is done with Aria Aria stands for
accessible rich internet applications
and it's a set of rules states and
properties that you can associate with
an HTML element to talk to the screen
reader so for in order to make this fake
button accessible I would actually give
it an aria role of button this tells the
screen reader that this element is
actually a button to make a get tab
focus when you tap to it I need to add a
tab index of zero to it and I also need
to make sure that it interacts to keep
with keyboard events just like it does
with Mouse events so let's take a look
at those over on Safari
interact with accessibility and fake
button button you are currently on
in sauk JavaScript why only respond to
Mouse events frown it was supposed to
show you that when I pressed enter with
a keyboard but something is messed up
with the keyboard navigation so I had to
use a mouse to pick it so I cheated but
you would have seen this nice dialogue
if it had worked with just the keyboard
um getting back to Michael's question um
our jobs would be really easy if all
accessibility problems were as simple to
fix as we saw in these few examples but
we often run into situations where you
have to be a bit clever about finding
solutions to your problems and I wanted
to show you an example of where we've
done that and that is with Facebook
photos we have billions of user
generated photos from people all around
the world on Facebook and we can't force
people all around the world to always
enter a caption or an alt text for their
photo so to solve this problem we built
something called the caption generator
the caption generator takes bits of
metadata associated with a photo who
uploaded the photo where was the photo
uploaded who are the people tagged in
the photo and it generates a caption or
in alt text for the image which we then
associated with the image so when voice
over lands on the photo it it announces
the snipes caption for the photo and I
don't know if we have time for the video
ok so let's take a look at a video
showing voiceover interacting with the
photos you'll notice that before we
apply the caption generator voiceover
announces something generate like link
image when we tap to a photo and after
we apply the caption generator it
announces a much richer description for
the photos
link link cover photo
Clint Andrew halls photo taken a kawase
untitled nighttime shot of the Coliseum
link image profile picture of Clint
Andrew hall link image link link link
Clint Andrew halls photo of Clint Andrew
hall and Arjun whoops allure taken out
aircraft carrier USS Hornet entitled on
the dock outside the USS Hornet such an
amazing place link image Clint Andrew
halls photo taken out aircraft carrier
USS Hornet entitled outside the party
link image Clint Andrew halls photo
taken out aircraft carrier USS Hornet
entitled the passenger received was a
nice touch everyone kept asking if the
barcode was real link image is going to
talk about making accessibility present
supposed to end with a couple quick
stories and let me just give you one
quick story then we I want to try to
answer this question which is why we
really here why was Facebook and PayPal
excited to come to Stanford and talk
about accessibility and the star that I
think captures that best is a story that
starts at Facebook so I want introduce
you to a front-end engineer named Jason
he is in his late 20s he graduated from
Carnegie Mellon University he's about to
get married in two weeks
it's very nice guy he was
working on a product called web
messenger web messenger if you use
Facebook in a desktop browser and you
send messages that's Jason's product so
when he was working on web messenger
about a year ago we were doing a large
refresh to this product I noticed that
there were going to be some challenge
with with it regards to accessibility
and compatibility in a screenreader so I
reached out to Jason and I asked him had
he tested his product for accessibility
and he tested it in a screen reader
jason's response was what's a screen
reader this is sort of the dreaded
response that you get as somebody's
working accessibility when he reached
out to an engineer and you asked them do
you know are they working on
accessibility for their product and
their responses I really don't know
anything about accessibility or what a
screen reader is so despite the fact
that Jason had graduated from you know
an outstanding engineering program had
passed the technical bar to work on
front-end at Facebook
he had no exposure to accessibility and
I'm not here to push Jason under the bus
I really don't think this is Jason's
fault in fact there are most of the
engineers that we work with at Facebook
have a similar experience as Jason
they've not been exposed to
accessibility in their training and so I
think it's a little bit difficult for us
to expect that the web is going to be
accessible if the people who are
building the web don't have much
understanding about accessibility so one
of the reasons why we're really excited
to come here was just to connect with
students like you guys working in design
and HCI and computer science who are
ultimately going to build the future web
and build future products we want you
guys to know earlier in the process you
know in your life cycles as developers
and as creators about accessibility so
that you can demand it from the products
that you're building and you know what
to do you have some best practices I
know that Romney moved pretty quickly
through some of the HTML demonstrations
but each one is I believe is escaped
from Google Navigation music so that's
the next time you are you know working
with a web team or building
that's like if you know those things you
can build a more accessible experience
and that's really what it's going to
take it's gonna it's gonna take a scaled
approach to this right not just a
handful of companies trying to solve
this but everyone who's building the web
to understand more about this and to
know what to do so I'll end there if we
have a you know some time for questions
we're happy to stay for a little bit but
thank you very much for your time
you